[Music]
the tourism industry is trying to cash
in on eclipses related travel
experiences and track is offering
special service in Illinois where the
eclipses darkness will last the longest
the train goes from Chicago to Champaign
to Carbondale and then back
tickets cost a hundred and fifty three
dollars from Chicago and $90 from
Champaign riding that train is Don
Dahler and he's on board the train as it
heads to Carbondale Don good morning hey
good morning we picked up a few more
passengers in Champaign Illinois they're
joining the folks in Chicago who boarded
in the middle of the night with us those
folks are taking a little nap they're
resting up for the day's events when
Amtrak announced this special train all
409 tickets sold out in less than a day
people thought you know what I don't
need to get a hotel room I don't need a
rental car that's a good look instead I
get a comfortable seat with complete
strangers to share a once-in-a-lifetime
experience in near total darkness thank
you very much we boarded the Amtrak
Eclipse Express to Carbondale early this
morning but passengers were anything but
sleeping why did the Sun quit college
because it already had a million degrees
they were full of jokes and anticipation
why are you going on this train and you
think that Carbondale is the best place
to save ya some came with their families
and others rode solo many coming from
near and far was bound and determined to
get
train and to see this total eclipse of
the Sun Amtrak employees handed out gift
bags with special eclipses viewing
sunglasses for wherever we chose to
watch mini will bus to Southern Illinois
University's football stadium for a NASA
watch part we arrived in Carbondale a
few hours before the moon crosses over
into the path of the Sun then we've got
some time to kill there during the event
itself and afterward when my new friend
Gabby and I will reboard the train
around 5:00 p.m. that's a 22 hour day
for less than a three-minute experience
but it's worth it right and we get these
really cool glasses Gail yes you can
tell Donna and Gabby really bonding
they're like hi dawn I can't wait to see
how they thought that works out for the
two of them Thank You Don Dahler